alors
et voilà vous arrivez bien j'allais
demander un verre de limonade à sabrina
vous venez avec moi alors on y va rené
sabrina tu as bien oui il dans sabrina
et j'aiderai soit fait je voudrais un
verre de limonade s'il te plaît d'accord
j'ai une soif à sa meute yachir elle est
bien fraîche
c'est vrai les rues de man bonne tout
est calme aujourd'hui je n'ai même pas
vu casimir
moi non plus mais c'est vrai il a
quasiment calciné
j'ai pas vu casimir non je le vois il
est en train de nettoyer sa magic fans
m'étonne plique toutes été aussi calme
n'est pas une petite affaire de mettre
de l'ordre dans une malle qui contient
temps de chauffe bien saurina on va
l'aider à ranger sa malle magique car
bien
les annuelles à françois sabrina tu
reviens on c'est gentil de venir me voir
veux tu que nous dédions aubin non merci
je viens juste de terminer c'est vrai
ouais mais leur casimir
on peut faire un jeu avec la belgique ah
oui oui un jeu quand vous voulez des
enfants christophe valérie evans
vous aussi venez venez dîner de parfaire
valérie y en a d'autres
christophe âge il est vite devenu berlin
voit là n'ont en fait pas comme ça tout
cela voilà vous êtes bien là alors
écoutez moi tous regarder moi j'écoutais
christophe téléphone alors voilà je vais
vous poser des questions à chacun et à
chacune d'entre vous et vous verrez si
vous savez pas la réponse est bien la
malle magique
cela donnera à casimir ouais ouais
d'accord tout le monde a compris qu'à
compris alors tout à coup ce qu'elle est
sexy bien compris je vais te demander
quelle est la capitale de l'angleterre
notre les autres on dit rien allez nom
du dirigeant christophe piguet alors
capitaine de l'angleterre
1 alors attendons la réponse
on va demander à la malle la malle
magique la réponse donne alors la rue
polonceau londres la réponse c'est lourd
dans ses salles du gardon pas nous avec
toi bon on pose une autre question
toi tu te lèves
donc on ne voit bien et du nous dit
qu'elle est le général qui avait inclus
vercingétorix 1
[Musique]
suit alors une question oui sabrina je
vais poser une question oui quel est le
nom d'un serpent hassan est tout à fait
tord c'est sabine sabine sa vie sa bile
quel est le nom de certains personnels
non c'est pas très gentil qu'est ce que
c'est six états pourra demander à la
malle alors allons y aller en banal
ahmad alwan tout cas voilà la réponse
le croate a fait c'est ça cet examen la
réponse c'est le talent ouais bien je
vous ai encore une autre question tient
à sabine de garde ta réponse avec toi
une autre question une autre capitale
qui va répondre la tient chez valérie
qui va répondre un tu es d'accord alors
qu'elle est la capitale du venezuela
et oui la capitale du venezuela c'est
compliqué ça bon alors la malle magique
va donner la réponse
casimir la peau du coup bah tu me la
donne c'est ça
caracas tard à caracas caracas la
capitale du venezuela tient sabine tpr
olympiens carte électorale
bon une dernière question quel est le
premier homme qui a marché sur la lune
on va demander à la baleine hélène c'est
pas moi qu'est ce que c'est la capitale
non le premier rhum
au point que les autres quel est le
premier homme qui a marché sur la lune
ah c'est pas bon la lamal ma demande et
à la logique de répondre aux aplats
voilà strong à la réponse amstrong cnn
voilà alors par mois avec les
formidables ballet vous savez elle peut
répondre à des questions encore plus
extraordinaire c'est vrai ouais ben
alors ces 6 me reposer d'autres
questions par exemple quel est le plus
célèbre tableau du monde
quel est le bon la malle magique de
retour d'attention personne fait en
alain pons de la même logique quoi c'est
la joconde un anneau non non non c'est
pas ça
mais ce que disent et la famine
sévissant le plus célèbre tableau du
monde ça s'appelle coucher de soleil sur
la mer des sargasses chardat lumière
voilà cette marque est idiote casimir ne
fâchent pas pour lui une autre question
alors par exemple quel est le plus
mauvais des serres du monde le plus
mauvais des serres du monde
réponse de la malle magique le plus
mauvais des serres du monde c'est le
lait blooming là à non non ah non c'est
pas ça du tout au contraire le
gloubiboulga c'est le meilleur dessert
du monde
1 qu'est ce qu'il ya de meilleur 1 les
enfants qu'est-ce qu'il ya le meilleur
que du chocolat avec que la banane
écrasée de la confiture de fraises de la
moutarde et de la saucisse de toulouse
et axel meilleurs experts non cette
manne est idiote dans sa quête nozuka
gym est allé poser une autre question
attention hein attention bon qu'elle est
l'être le plus intelligent du monde à
on va voir un pouce de l'analogique
l'être le plus intelligent du monde
s'est réjoui me jacques un qui est
révisable vous connaissez vous mais moi
j'ai jamais entendu parler non moi non
plus toi non plus n'aime pas ça et toi
sabine remise à gouesnou
vous avez entendu parler c'est bizarre
on va interroger là maintenant c'est pas
sa façon
rim isaac contraire de casimir ah oui je
comprends moi je comprends pas mais je
vais t'expliquer remy sachs et casimir
excellent vert on commence par là
dernier relais
on continue ainsi de suite 120 casino
mais alors je comprends intelligent
contraire d' imbéciles c'est à dire que
si l'homme le plus intelligent du monde
série mizac l'homme le plus imbécile du
monde
il sait comme la malle magique et très
méchant non je ne suis quand même pas si
idiot koussa enfin les noms qu'ils aient
mes attentes attendant il ya la malle
magique est en train d'écrire autre
chose je ne le pensais pas ça ses bras
cou et a versé la marque
merci ça